[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to season five of black Mara has
just dropped on Netflix and the new show
has a hell of a lot to unpack from it
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down Rachel a Jack and Ashley to
starring Miley Cyrus and giving my
thoughts on the meaning behind its
ending this is full spoilers ahead so if
you haven't seen the show yet and don't
want anything roon for yourself then I
highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video I
hope you enjoy it now sit back relax and
let's get into my ending explain
breakdown a Rachel Jack and Ashley - we
follow Rachel impressionable teenager
who is obsessed with Ashley Oh
role model who is literally on a roll
achieving her goals something something
selling you a dollar eats his soul her
intelligent companion Ashley - is
sweeping across America inspiring all to
live their best life but everything
isn't as it seems similar to those
purchasing the doll Ashley is depressed
on medication feeling isolated and needs
a pick-me-up maybe she should buy in
Ashley - doll a hey no anyway this is
reflected by Rachel who too is
struggling to make new friends due to
her recent family relocation and both
really come across as disconnected and
willing to pour their hearts into
anything that will give them some
attention no matter how shallow Rachel
after getting in Ashley - for her
birthday pours her heart into the doll
fixating on it as the only positive
thing in her life Rachel begins to mimic
Ashley in every way
even performing it dance based off the
singer that goes disastrously she soon
discovers however that in trying to live
her life as someone else that she will
never be able to mirroring this ashley
begins having an identity crisis and
realizing that she is living a lie in
order to please those around her you see
here as a commodity rather than a person
to me the persona of Ashley o represents
how we can believe that others are
living perfect lives and use this facade
to find fault in our own Ashley and
Rachel are both as
happy is one another however the latter
is unable to see this and thus does not
recognize the reality of the situation
which is that she should not be
idolizing her and she will only end up
once more in the spiral of an happiness
personally I think it's a comment on the
hashtag living my best life thing that's
going around on Instagram and how we
often only show people aspects of our
lives if we are showing off
Rachel aspires to this and ultimately
ends up disappointed when she's not as
loved as she is with Ashley - and tried
to live our lives as others we will
inevitably fail and this only end up
disappointed jack Rachel's sister
realizing this hides the Ashley to doll
just as the real Ashley begins to cut
out the poisonous aspects of her life
however it's too late and Ashley is put
into a chemical coma by her overly
possessive aunt that will mean that she
can't breach contract them either
symbolizes that often breaking our bar
routines of obsession is never easy and
we must first in a way kill our fake
online selves in order to have a rebirth
which is what happens to the character
throughout the latter part of the
episode after Rachel's actually to
reactivates her and a sister discovered
that the dog contains Ashley's entire
consciousness within the machines
honestly at this point in the episode
kind of lost me a bit and knowing that
it was the last episode of season 5 they
left me slightly disappointed how the
run had been overall I really hope the
childsplay reboot is better than this
because there's nothing worse than
seeing an Alexa on wheels roll around
the house creating mischeif sorry I
don't know that one shut up man
anyway actually - turns off the
life-support machine on Ashley and this
destabilizes the coma allowing her to
awaken and rush to the launch of
Ashley's latest reincarnation
Ashley 3 right now Ashley eternal
basically 2pac at Coachella
Ashley manages to stop the launch dead
in its tracks and we see Ashley's career
reborn as the rock star that yous always
meant to be in the end this is about
following a path that's best for us
rather than what others want who are
purely out to manipulate and how those
that appear to be happy with the perfect
image often aren't whilst it is an issue
that I can agree with overall I found
this episode poorly handled and it was
one of the most disappointing in the
show that I've ever seen it just didn't
have the black mirror aspect to it I've
come to love and overall it felt like a
teen pop drama that Wilde spit the
Netflix isn't right for the show in my
opinion this was a huge disappointment
as a whole I feel like season 5 will be
regarded as the dud in the show that
many will look back on with this day in
the end this is probably one of the
worst Black Mirror episodes ever and
nurse it gets a low four out of ten
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the episode and what you took from it
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoy this video then please like it and
make sure you check out my breakdown of
smithereens would you be linked at the
end this is the channel for people who
are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]